yeah they've got jt brubacher in six
games this year he's been two and two
with a two seven eight thirty two and a
third innings pitched only eight walks
and 37 strikeouts so
just okay called third strike a little
delay
well big delay by pat hober matt hoberg
did his best tim mcclellan
impersonation just now lefty hitting
jesse winker the left fielder
right against the grain of the shift
winker takes a turn
he's going to challenge for second kai
tom's throw skips away
all the hustle from jesse winker he is
at second for nick castiano's
and there's a called third strike at the
knees
inside corner and as he walks away
castellanos like a baton
tosses the bat in the air catches it on
the other end not happy
i thought he called it a ball again
lucas draws the two out walk
two on two out naquin coming up pops
this ball up
and foul territory the third baseman
gonzalez now drifting into fair
territory will make the catch
and after a half inning it's the reds
nothing the pirates coming to bat
started off really solid hoffman did
first three or four outings were very
good
uh last outing against the white sox not
so much but it's a good team to bounce
back against right here
slaps it hits it the other way it's
going to drop in there for
another opposite field hit and that's a
12-game hitting streak for frasier the
batter is brian reynolds
to left tailing away and the sun field
and winker can't get it
it's an automatic double frazier
advances two bases
and that is the 13th double for brian
reynolds
well now it's philip evans and the
infield will come in swinging a miss
struck him out breaking ball down and
away and
evans carved up for out number one and
just when
hoffman really needed a strikeout he
gets a big one here
jacob stallings up there now with
runners at second and third one away
and he smokes the first pitch to short
great pick
by kyle farmer runners have to freeze
two down now the pirates need two out
action here with runners at second and
third it's eric gonzalez
here comes frazier in the score the
pirates with an early lead
he was ready to backhand a horrible job
of with a man at third base and
you know a curveball in the dirt didn't
even try to block it
swinging a miss elevated a fastball and
blew it right
by eric gonzalez the inning is over
buckos one
reads nothing it'll be suarez to lead
things off and it's a little tapper
toward third
off the bat of suarez tough play at
third for gonzalez he throws way late
nauhenio suarez beats it out
that's an infield single to start the
reds second inning
two outs now in the second so here's
jeff hoffman and he dribbles this one in
front of the dirt circle
picked up by stallings turns and gets
the pitcher running and
hoffman almost beat that throw after two
innings from pnc park
and senzel is aboard to start the third
and that'll bring jesse winker to the
play
senzelle been caught stealing four times
[Music]
and he's out he's been thrown out five
times
i'm not sure what they're thinking right
there with a 3-0 count on winker one of
the best hitters in the national league
right now i'm not sure what the benefit
of
winker unloads brubacher knows where
that's going
devastation
get the deep sea divers ready need to
retrieve a souvenir
a seventh home run for jesse winker
bottom of three coming up in pittsburgh
pitcher jt
brewbaker began the inning by walking on
five pitches reynolds
joined him and out later brings up
philip evans
swing and a miss breaking ball that was
in the zone and no chance for evans
a third strikeout for hoffman so two
down here's jacob stalling
and it is hammered into center field but
naquin is going to be there he'll make
the catch
and that'll be the final out of the
third going to the fourth inning
jt brubacher will be facing tyler naquin
slapped on to gonzales nice boy
spins and fires and gets the first out
two quick outs for brubacher
tucker barnhart and a called third
strike one two
three and out head to the bottom of the
fourth one on one out and that'll bring
up kevin newman
oh you can just swat one out the left
that one's deep
winker trying to swat it
see tom run
he's in newman the third with an rbi
triple
triple and a 2-1 pirates lead in the
fourth
that was very odd looking in the
outfield wait winker went at that ball
it was like he didn't really see it all
that well
but it was hit to the very deepest part
watch this look at the bench behind him
now the infield comes in troy stokes jr
at the plate
a great time for his first hit and ribby
tip to left and it's down troy stokes jr
with his first
major league hit and give him a run
batted in
newman scores three to one buckos what a
great feeling that's got to be for him
first knock an rbi in a tight ball game
there's no taking that one away from him
3-1 fifth inning two outs
now nick senzel he's one for two the 1-0
and sinzell rips a line drive it'll want
to hop into the outfield for a base hit
two out single for nick sinzell his
second hit of the ball game
he's aboard for jesse winker who's two
for two with a double and a homer
and a high fly ball he just missed that
one
way up there shallow right second
baseman
frazier's out on the grass to make the
catch four and a half played
pirates three reds one reynolds has been
on base
every single time he's now reached base
safely seven straight plate appearances
to philip evans
hits that one that's gonna roll near the
wall
[Applause]
it doesn't die to the warning track boy
he hit that one hard
and drives in reynolds phillip evans
with the rbi
4-1 pirates couldn't have put that one
in a better spot
i mean it split them perfectly and
reynolds
easily coming around the bases on that
4-1 the pirates lead sixth inning
castianos will lead off for cincinnati
against jt rubik
hit hard towards center and moving a few
steps into right center field
gracefully the catch made by brian
reynolds here's mustaches
says balls popped up toward right
heading near the line is troy stokes
jr and he puts it away for the second
out tyler naquin now
and in the air to center back a couple
of steps
under it reynolds makes the catch quick
work there for
jtb after five and a half pirates four
reds one just a moment ago
pretty much official ending of a
starting pitcher's night the manager's
embrace yeah he doesn't look too happy
about it stokes will get the walk
he's aboard with one out now adam
frazier stokes runs
and he's in with stolen base number one
got a good break right there off perez
going on first movement
first hit first rbi first stolen base
ground ball right to the first baseman
mustacha so
it's not going to matter mustaches will
take it three unassisted the bag
pirates are done in the sixth new
pitcher is david fednar
he will go to work here against nick
sinzell if there's one team that has
been able to get to bednar it has been
the reds
opposite way that's a fair ball but then
ricochet
off the umpire hit the bag
that's as fair as they come now jesse
winker got the right guys
in the right spot here fastball
ripped into left field fair ball kicks
corner
senzel flies to third stop sign he goes
through it
and they eat it down to third winker
dead to rights
a costly costly out senzelle
burned through the stop sign and scores
but winker backside nabbed
trying to grab an extra bag boy that is
a costly mistake by jesse winker for the
first out of this inning and we go to
the bottom of the eight here's troy
stokes jr now runner at first
there's a ground ball inside the third
base bag newman had taken off
on the pitch troy stokes into second
base with his first career double
what a night for the right troy stokes
jr
his rbi double scores newman and the
pirates take a 5-2 lead
troy stokes jr with his second hit his
second rbi
adam frazier now comes to the plate he
extended his hitting streak to 12
straight games with his
first inning single that one hit well
toward the wall and it rattles and rocks
at the top
that won't drop a home run the first of
the year for adam frazier
adam frazier gives the pirates a 7-2
lead
home run number one pirates are leading
seven to two
and uh richard rodriguez comes on
here's a pop-up who's got it in foul
ground and now in fair territory eric
gonzalez drifts out onto the outfield
grass to make the catch
raise the jolly roger it's a nice
all-around effort for the pirates
tonight and good to see troy stokes jr
not only get
his first major league hit but two of
them and driving a pair everybody
seemed to contribute tonight